mro congratulations what an incredible
game a lot of preparation a lot of back
and forth between uh you two guys he was
very well prepared as well but you
matched that consistently tell us a bit
about this game where did you feel that
you're taking over the
initiative okay first of all Christian
could you do me a favor today and not
tell me what the engine moves are like
sure of course I understand the reason
is that after after I go back to my
hotel room I always try to retry the
positions that I missed in the game okay
okay and that's your training I remember
I remember that you mentioned that
during the Juniors yes but how do you
still have the energy to do
that well okay it's it comes with time
all right tell us about the game so yeah
this game was very very interesting like
this first move H4 I didn't know like I
think Rook F3 uh B takes A4 this is this
was all my preparation
mhm now the point point is in this
position instead of H4 I knew like Rook
F7 Queen d8 and like Knight H7 I think
is some line apparently okay of course
engine says triple zeros but it's still
very very complicated like A3 here and
black gets A3 and black gets counterplay
right so he play this move so in the
game yeah so now H4 is a very
interesting move because now my piece is
like now when you look at this without
an engine it looks very strange because
all your pieces are kind of stuck on the
back Rank and your Pawn structure is
completely ruined and it's like what
what do you play right
like one idea I was considering here was
Knight B6 but Knight B6 fails to I think
it was Rook F7 Queen d8 Rook takes
C7 so now you cannot take with the queen
you have to take with the King and then
Knight takes C6 you consider this be
good for
white yes because uh the the main line
here goes like say Rook takes E6 Queen
takes E6 and now Queen takes D4 is
impossible due to Queen F7 check Knight
D7 E6
mhm yeah
so okay maybe I'm pretty sure I must
have missed like 20 things here but my
idea was Queen d8 The Point
train after that so we're not going to
tell you anything sure sure tell us a
bit about this another C move I had here
was C5 because of course if if C5 ever
works it's the move you always want to
play because everything opens up and
your position starts looking a lot
better but now the issue is Rook F7 uh
Queen d8 mhm Bishop takes B7 yes I think
uh King takes B7 but actually Rook D1
here you have Knight takes C5 W but yeah
this is the line I calcul like Rook D1
Knight takes C5 I think it was Queen E4
check Knight C6 Knight takes C6 by the
way is this completely over after Rook
takes
C7 yeah H yes but Rook yeah that was
also Rook C7 tak7 King takes C7 Knight
E6 Knight D6 takes takes Knight F3 yeah
Knight F3 King G2 Knight takes D4 Queen
takes C4 like yeah I think white is
probably a bit better but this doesn't
not look too clear to me right queen
queen A8 yeah this is looking good for
you so I think the main issue was
instead of yeah after Knight Knight
takes E5 this queen E4 but so I played
this idea of Queen d8 the point of Queen
d8 is now every time I go C5 you don't
have uh Rook F7 with tempo right the
other thing play with the yes and now
okay now I was very happy like I then I
kind of knew that Queen d8 was not that
bad because okay Rook I can get this
position by Rook F7 Queen d8 H for
right so you guys got to this position
this was another critical moment when he
played this move and he thought for a
long time about this idea of Queen H7
Queen G8 Knight H7 he was trying to uh
create something from behind how did you
assess this one how did you come to the
conclusion that G6 has to be the right
move yeah this was frankly one of the
scariest moments of the game because
this queen H7 at first I underestimated
this like no like once I realized that
Queen G8 Knight H7 was a threat like my
first idea was to go G6 and this is what
eventually I did but I was very worried
like when I was calculating I was
worried that if I go G6 Rook F7 the most
natural move after Rook F7 is of course
to play Rook takes F7 immediately right
but I believe that this is a mistake
because after Rook takes F7 Knight takes
F7 now every time I go C5 I don't attack
E5 like I think here you can even go
like say Bishop takes B7 King takes B7 D
takes E5 and then take on G6 and this is
basically just like much worse version
of the game because now H Pawn just
starts running I don't have too much
real counterplay
yeah so you played C5 first after Rook
to F7 by the way did you consider Knight
to F7 after
G6 yes I considered this but I thought
uh Knight F7 I thought Knight D5 Bishop
takes D5 I think here e takes
D5 okay like of course maybe I would
still calculate and come up with
something different but my idea behind
this was that somewhere I can go C5 like
say rookie 6 after Queen G6 Rook E6 and
say queen G4 maybe C5 or yeah Queen G8
C5 got it but okay maybe actually Knight
G5 might be some issue here but yeah
still I need to I need to check out the
details but you played Rook F7 and now
you're starting to take over Queen to E4
yeah this was also a very critical
moment after like Queen E4 because Queen
E4 I actually have a couple different
options instead of Knight D5 I had King
B6 and King B8
the most natural move is of course King
B8 but now Knight D6 uh Bishop takes D6
e takes D6 and now if I go Knight B5 you
have Queen C6 yeah yeah I tried to make
this work by going A6 but okay this
feels very okay I don't want to go I I
really didn't want to go into this go a
knight a king A6 here or what no no King
A6 here there's Queen C6 or here A6 yes
yeah here A6 got it and now like Queen
takes C now okay this position I really
wasn't sure but I I I liked what I did
in the game a lot more because other
than King B8 King B uh King B6 was
another move I calculated mhm but King
B6 I was worried that he can go Queen
takes D4 check the whole point of King
B6 is okay in this Knight D6 line you
don't have Queen C6 so I can take and go
Knight B5 and I have all this but you
play this move Knight D5 which
definitely feels like the right move
you're keeping more pawns on the board
especially with this move Queen to h8
you had to find it you did find it and
right now the pressure is on your
opponent and I have to say yeah Queen h8
was a very nice move because I kept all
my Center I kept my Center intacted
because if I lose D4 for example I can
basically I can almost resign frankly
because he has too many the H Pawn is is
is going along but you did not lose and
when you lost it you managed to create
another weapon the C Pawn that
ultimately became uh your uh tool for
victory so congratulations abiani 2 and
a half out of three was that anywhere in
your dreams that you would start uh so
well in your first US
championships no no I was just I came
here hoping to play my best chess I
didn't really think about the results
but it feels amazing frankly to be the
sole leader of the US Championship
congratulations go uh get your energy
back up look at the game with your dad
and we'll see you tomorrow our thank you
our congratulations to you as well Misha
very very deser